so you've done a couple podcasts yeah
done so we've got to talk about Duty a
little bit but first you did for several
years you did the 10 Minute Podcast yeah
I mean everything is hilarious about
that podcast including the fact that
it's 10 minutes right that means every
it's ridiculous it's absurd the dynamic
is hilarious it's you Brian Callum
crystalia there I I don't know exactly
why it's
why it works so well but it did it
worked really well I think it's because
the yeah you were having fun probably I
mean that's that would really
came through that it was friends just
talking [ __ ] and attention the beautiful
tension and the absurdity they came out
yeah uh what sure what was the story of
making that podcast what how did that
came to be uh why do you think it was as
good as it was I don't know I feel like
that podcast was like
it was
our our who we kind of are but on
steroids or something like you know uh
each person you know Brian's going to be
like extra manly and and uh can you get
any more mailing than he already is no
yeah he reaches though uh and yeah we
just kind of it's I I feel like as
goofballs we knew each other's line yeah
like here's the line you don't cross I
feel like those guys don't really have
one uh but at least they knew mine
um and and yeah we were able to just
yeah goof around and I did it with them
for three years and then Chad who I'm
doing doozy with and my pal Tommy
blachio is a another writer producer
like Chad they came on and yeah all told
we did I did like
seven years of that thing six five six
seven I don't remember
do you think it ever comes back in some
small form as as a 20 minute podcast or
something like that
I mean is there uh because it's one of
the most requested I mean there's you
you have a huge fan base I'm 47 years
old so I am of the generation that had a
cell phone has had a cell phone half the
time and didn't for the formative years
of my life into my early 20s
um and then finally got a like I got a
cell phone I guess I was like 19 or
something just like literally just
because I'm moving to La you got porn in
the mail you got yes that's right it was
that the hard the hardcover porn that's
the way we liked it bound you know nice
binding on the on the porn the leather
uh next to the Bible yeah yep
um these are all my these are my
Encyclopedia Britannica wow very
impressive yes a man came to the house
and sold me these and then down here
these are my this is my pornography uh
if you'll follow me through here to The
Parlor uh sir and pass through the
generations from Grandfather to Father
yeah I want to give you something very
special to me Nebuchadnezzar
um but uh uh if you go up in the
generation without a cell phone yes I um
it's hard for me to connect with people
who
who hit me up I look at everything as
polling so if one person hits me up and
shares this opinion but two other people
hit me up and share that I'm the worst
I'm don't follow my polls my when people
say oh that poll means absolutely
nothing
so-and-so is going to win anyway that
that's my pull my poll means nothing but
I do look at the stuff and go uh this
many people are saying this that means
that that number is saying that and yet
it's very hard for me to uh hear what
the hell people are saying online yeah I
really I can't connect to it sometimes
personally So when you say that that's a
popular podcast like I know that I know
that it's popular with the people that
have expressed that they love it yeah
you know what I mean what does that
actually represent I don't know I don't
know what kind of people are the
audience I don't know I know that the
the people that listen to the 10 Minute
Podcast and if you did thank you uh and
we're friends uh I know that it was a it
was a special thing because it's like
you know just doing this out of my house
and we just built it up out of nowhere
and we're just kind of clowning around
it's a it's an odd thing I hope I I pers
I think I I speak for the two people
that have reached out to you that said
you should do it or whatever three
people the poll yeah that uh you should
bring it back at some point that would
be beautiful maybe uh it's like uh
what's what's a good story of some of
like a famous band that came back and
was successful probably well Nirvana no
it was not
sorry I got Nirvana mixed up with
Aerosmith yeah it was Aerosmith yeah
I had that second ride different yeah
totally different ending of those two
bands one ended up on uh American Idol
yeah
um a lot of interesting women involved
in that one too